et messieurs bonsoir merci pour votre
accueil et de réserver ce dernier de
courage mais le président attend se
trouve comme bon je vais commencer par
une annonce
voilà je suis désolé pour les gens
pouvaient choquer ici excuse moi mais
nous ce différend la séquence la kabylie
news la mettait en scène nouvelle crise
et l'humour loi doit d'accomplir cet
appareil pas seulement sa orangé rodwell
regardez avoir gardé la gauche et vous
allez tomber face à face avec des gens
qui sont totalement différents
différent pas forcément opposé les
différends par la physique différent par
l'esprit est différent
par expérience savez ce petit chemin
assuré que bacon et secondes et la
france ont brillé à ce petit chemin qui
nous a appris à ce qu'on a fonction de
ce qu'on a réussi à se reprendre et
échoue finalement à discerner ce qu'on
va manger aussi est impossible alors la
poser les mains des différents et en
tant que personne indifférente à part
bien sûr c'est impossible donc à six
fours et vous serez pas l'incident n'a
pas eu cette notion d'un possible sur
votre route
et pour moi ça a commencé très tous nés
en 92 j'aurais tendance à dire 1980 nous
semble un peu mieux
j'ai six mois autant juillet est le plus
mes parents s'amusent à venir et leur
bébé dont ils sont super fier et je les
en petits d'outils fois quelque chose au
fond des yeux des yeux de chat tir
flaire alors les familles s'inquiètent
pas spécialement on sait pas trop quel
âge ouvre carrément le mélange bizarre
ce histoire hélas médecins s'agitent
il faut faire réligion c'était super
faut aller aux urgences et la sentence
tombe cancer cancer n'a réussi à six
mois on y croira forcément et pourtant
commencé une partie de poker avec les
cartes round
j'adore le poker j'ai pas eu une superbe
et pourtant et pourtant je le fais
existe parce que le concerto gruissan il
était impossible que gens sortent avec
un restaurant visuel et pour mes parents
tous étaient impossibles n'était pas
possible il avait cet espoir là alors
ils sont blessés parfois contre contre
les ml qu on sait tous mais une tranchée
mais des généraux j'ai quelques soldats
qui comprend pas grand chose étant pour
les jeunes qui ont délibérément parce
que nous on veut survivre
on est tous faudrait pour ça la petite
cellule à l'organisme le plus complexe à
leurs âmes
alors j'ai cru que j'allais chez sotchi
et leurs espoirs et travail est énorme
quelques d'alépé d'un j'ai 15 ans je
suis ni vers l'école maternelle et là
mes parents je dirais un petit gamin pas
tout à fait ordinaire parce que bon
alors il ya un restaurant visuel devant
son écran il a le groove est dans la
forme
mes copains me demandais si je pouvais
pousser les mâles
pour corriger une vue très effrayante
mais très tôt condamné le pouvoir voire
au parti nous on va en parler parce que
bon on appelle ça le relais par
convention ou ne s'était pas ni la
question mais la sphère début d'année
dernière à nîmes beaucaire longue
bataille médical mais bon malgré tout
que jamais mon petit pense convoquer en
dessous petit sourire j'étais content et
puis j'avais me dirai pas moi la rage au
jeu voir la mère je veux dire ma main
est largement relatées ont fait rire n'a
pas trop su briller à quitter l'algérie
le jour où tu fais tu ne nous est
montrée en péril ses habitudes j'ai pas
compris pourquoi les nouvelles et mises
d'accord alors à noël j'ai eu une joie
où l'on contrebalancé ça j'ai la
première console de jeux multi ton fier
de contempler les 900 kg
j'ai pu rêver devant tous ces trucs là
j'ai pu être tout à la fois un pilote de
course
le sujet n'a été mis en chasse deux
vaisseaux spatiaux un plombier qui
cassent compromis et puis un super héros
oui mais pas choisi ouanna pour
l'opération c'était 7 par spider man que
j'ai connu dans ma vie j'étais fan de
spiderman j'adorais les couleurs rouge
est demeuré les remises
je n'aurais tout ça alors daredevil
l'homme sans peur tout ce qu'on nous
empêche d'être qui on veut c'est la peur
vous prenez rien
un maire qui n'y voient pas le jour qui
est avocat qui fait une sentence pour
les poteaux tels moyens et qu'il a fini
par l'effort de la justice sur le belge
eric avec le modèle alors voilà j'ai
continué j'ai grandi j'ai passé les
niveaux dans les jeux vidéo futur battre
un record astronomiques dans les
compteurs 2000 parce que je suis mort je
crois qu'on vient de hollande j'ai
réessayé plus arriver petit à petit j'ai
passé les classes changer les jeux dans
les progrès qui avec mes copains ou en
voyant ce que changer les casques et
afin de s'échanger des dessins sur fil
de petites manches mardi
et puis avec les autres copains qui moi
hier en séminaire je vous dis à la corde
à sauter achats jeu contre les boss
france des platanes fer d'origine
avenant porte parce que j'ai remarqué
aussi que les personnes qui tombaient
autour de - la plupart étaient pourvus
d'une jolie paire d'yeux fonctionnel
quelque part c'est rassurant et je me
suis dit j'ai appris j'ai pas eu peur de
découvrir
il remet jamais appris à avoir peur de
découvrir ou désigner qu'un jour j'ai eu
la chance au grand bonheur de faire la
rencontre qui a changé analyse dans un
palais club j'aurais organisé par le
centre de loisirs dont la rubrique est
alors la chambre le soir
plein de petites étoiles parce qu'il me
restait deux yeux
musée mais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
doit aussi content d'une écoute c'est
pas compliqué je ferme lâche pas je
ferme le ban et j'adore ça j'ai fait
venir il va pouvoir embarquer dans
l'avion finalement qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait elle a pris sur elle de chercher de
recevoir et même des refus s'il fallait
recevoir sans me le dire
et un jour jean bart en voiture sans
trop savoir où on va et puis le même
volet centré pièce où la belle position
mouche le vieux-lille cheval un peu trop
grand pour moi et moi hier pas trop
assurément mais quel plaisir
la commission s'était qu'on commence
d'abord offert connaissances en cours
particuliers et ensuite on verrait si ça
fonctionne bien
en 2004 je commence entre particuliers
quelques mois je prends vous premiers
boys les premières chutes de revenir là
je vous signale que tous débutants mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait plein alors
j'apprends jours les choses de la vie
font que vous voyez l'étagé je suis
attristé la région parisienne ce club
qui m'a accepté jeudi est ce que je vais
trouver aussi bien
donc j'ai pas trouvé bien j'ai trouvé
mieux je débarque dans un club qui a
déjà dû gérer la compétition pour des
personnes aveugles et qu'ils me voient
non plus comme une colonne spécificité
caractéristiques qui sera sec et 10 me
voient comme une opportunité
j'étais leur défi pédagogique
tiffany et la monitrice à l'époque même
pas regardé blomet rang sur elle de
l'enseigné elle me dit d ailleurs on les
fait suivre un cochon qui me levant et
puis avec les indications vocales
il enchaîne un parcours d'obstacles à la
reprendrais cei et puis revenir et on
est engagé sur quelques vous font quoi
nationaux internationaux parfois
revendre et l'histoire je me rappelle un
petit peu moins dans tout ça je me fais
plaisir et bien longtemps pour tomber
les gens descendent
parce que je suis r alors je redescends
jean deviendra walker ordinaire genre
devient le petit à l'aune du lycée alors
j'étais en seconde j'ai des passionnés
de science et pour une raison obscure
vous savez bien c'est vous connu deux
albums ça fait un bail
alors j'ai un peu le céder à la pression
des enseignants de sciences
bon peut-être par flemme da par peur je
sais par où dalle peut-être pris sur moi
ne pas écouter la peur bref je suis
heureux je suis un con signé et je tiens
mon bac littéraire
pendant que je continue mes études et
puis après je regarde dans nos études de
kinésithérapie et la ligne ont acquis
mais il faut en effet il faut un bac s
alors maintenant je bûche je décroche
son diplôme universitaire équivalent au
bac s voilà premières vont en revanche
et d'erevan
comme quoi les aveo ça peut faire est
bien souvent la chefferie du défi je me
rends compte que je suis passionnée
d'équitation budget passionné de deux
confrontations aussi avec les cavaliers
parce qu'ils ne sont qu'amas et non pas
seulement parce qu'ils sont différents
alors on cherche comment s'approcher au
mieux de ce que font tous les jeunes
retrouvent avec des personnes à pied et
et guider les personnes qui donnent des
indications vocales et on retrouve tout
seul sans manches à faire mes propres
foudre et votre choix et tournant et là
dedans dit fanny m'accompagne toujours
des à lèvres et je fais des rencontres
est recalé qui décide d'être aussi font
quoi philippe rodier médaillés
olympiques à rio pour nsn des rencontres
ou jamais j'aurais espéré faire et
j'avais j'aurais cru et championnat
lille le roman était aussi mais
finalement on y parvient et puis
d'autres défis moi le jour cette année
on a décidé car en décembre dernier
doser le défi de la hauteur au profit de
l'association
on se dit tiens est ce qu'un aveugle
peut sauter ou alors sur le formal là on
appelle la puissance pour le sort hôtels
en chine et on y parvient et je retrouve
à franchir deux auteurs de mettre 40
devant un public aussi a écrit du commun
puisque j'aime bien me préparer avec
leur super choix est là dessus a
toujours nié auquel est opposée dès les
premiers mots de ce bois et tiffany
depuis plus de 10 ans qui après avoir
cru en ma folle il a du mal à croire la
sienne aujourd'hui parce que ce sont par
exemple en tous cas très ordinaire et le
2 mai dernier
en revanche ça a été sur cette phrase
qui tourne depuis une heure dans mon
esprit il a été sept il me rappelait ma
mère n'avait pas voulu embarquer dans
dans mon ami en mode entier vous avez
réussi à vous en vous car la belgique en
très loin des associations savez les
millions au volant qui permet les
personnes non voyantes et malvoyantes de
piloter des avions secours manoir si
vous êtes passionné d'aviation et
malheureusement je suis pas dans le jeu
pas trouvé les sentiers battus donc vous
pouvez dans moi et j'ai appris le tarn
agit alors que j'en ai été capable
j'avais dit maman tu m'accompagnes assad
qui va grimper avec moi dans ma vie
alors moi j'ai un physique et on affaire
à quelques tours retrouva autour de fort
boyard mais par une jolie mur sinon je
leur laisse profiter et c'est
franchement aujourd'hui mais n'ont pas
forcément un cadeau comme une simple
erreur apparente qui ne sait pas parce
qu'elle trouvait jusque là c'était que
par l'agriculteur me dire tu sais tu
auras l'élégie devra travailler dix foix
plus que pour voir il n'a pas tout en
satisfaisant
et pour y arriver les efforts que j'ai
déploiera seront je trouve non pas à
toujours perçu une part et les défis que
tu saisira ne sera apprêté parfois le
seul à les contrôler ou allemand est
dans ton choix
pas mal de personnes te diront ça c'est
impossible
nous sommes bons dans son combat pour la
survie est bon à prendre
la poursuite la seule leçon que je tire
de tout ça c'est que vous au bon endroit
je crois que l'impossible est un bon
début
[Applaudissements]